Well,
how are you? Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his brief News Now report in
Spanish after a hard meeting of
the board of directors of
the county school district with Dr. Jesús Jara, he is
no longer the superintendent, this happened
after a vote of four to three  in favor
of Jara being removed from his position
cavazos cp de aforo and guzmán voted in
favor of this decision the board also
discussed the position of linda
cavazos an issue that remains pending
the roof min is also observed as the
day of snowfall but as this  The year falls on a
sunday the state birthday is observed
on friday this means
schools and government offices
will be closed among other places
as well as banks there will be a
variety of events celebrating halloween
around bayern families will be able to
enjoy a movie the movie
plays  at lawrence and park
on saturday night there will also be another
movie night at the ankle- center
pool and  the wine will be an event in
tetuán build on sunday in
business science and a carnival in the
kirchner community center and we close the
week with quite
pleasant temperatures let's see here the acquaintance
reaches them we will reach 80 degrees
by friday we will also see
some clouds for  Saturday but
we will have a clear sky for
Sunday Halloween I am Cristian
Cásseres with your brief
news now in Spanish
good day
[Music]